what was it like for you i mean this is
a thought-provoking heavy show how did
you leave it at work if at all yeah no
yeah i had to figure out how to do that
yeah because i didn't want to take it
home yeah so no i just i just kind of
like thankfully it was like there's a
good crew out there in calgary and this
cast is such good fun and you know we
had a great time together i think we
just tried to have as much fun when we
weren't
on set as possible really and even on
set you know it's i think that that's
what has to happen when you make
something that's so heavy and dark is
that you have to really
find the lightness in any way like
gallows humor in any way you kind of can
yeah so how do you recommend do people
need a glass of wine to watch it some
stress now
you know what you know what's cool is it
it's it's i mean cool is the wrong word
but it is a thriller it is a it is a
true crime thriller
that is dealing with some pretty dark
and heavy themes but like there's it's
thrilling you know i saw it so i think
it's
i think it's enough to just kind of like
go along for the ride and and yeah you
know if you if you want to have a glass
of wine i'm not going to say you
shouldn't but whatever you want to do
whatever your poison your ca the love
that you showed this man having for his
family
i mean it jumped through the screen at
me the moments with his daughters
they're so touching what was it like for
you to portray those relationships and
what did you pull from
yeah i mean like it was vital because
you needle you need lightness in the
midst of all of this and you need love
and you need warmth and
i think it's a kind of vital ingredient
that will that will hopefully keep keep
audiences um
you know because it can't just be being
beat over the head with with the
heaviness
yeah yeah and i think that it's it's
like a light a light patch in the middle
of a lot of dark yeah i gotta ask you if
fans went crazy the other day you and
toby mcguire went to a screening
together and they went nuts just for
that what is it about his friendship
that's so special to you and could we
see you two do another project together
i would love to work with toby i mean
like he's such a great actor and he's a
good buddy and i really just love him i
love spending time with him and yeah we
went and saw this incredible film
everything everywhere
all at once which is a genius
masterpiece of creativity with the
incredible michelle yo and these two
incredible directors called the daniels
and
everyone will see it and everyone will
fall in love with it in the same way
that we did and yeah it was great fun
and to share with yeah i know i i love
him and i would love to to make
something with him for sure